I remember shooting my first roll of 35
millimeter film it was during a hiking
trip up Mount Baldy in Southern
California during whiteout conditions
now minus the soaking wet shoes it was
without question one of the top three
hikes of my life and I was absolutely
blown away at the shots I got back from
the lab its Adventures like this that
get me so inspired to create so today
I'll be using these shots as inspiration
from my next piece of 3D art and I'll
walk you guys through my entire process
for creating this looping snowy
landscape but first I gotta give a shout
out to Asus for sponsoring this video
definitely stick around to learn all
about their new Pro Art Studio Book Pro
16 OLED laptop and how it can help you
create 3D art from anywhere in the world
so you guys probably know by this point
I've been using Unreal Engine a whole
lot this year it's been an absolute
blast so I'm going to use it to create
my very last piece of art this year as
well but you guys can use any program
you want to implement all these tools
techniques tips and tricks so I'm going
to use the game preset here and hop into
a blank level with Ray tracing enable
now I want to prep our environment with
three things to help us create
effectively first I'll add a reference
character which is huge for judging the
scale of our scene any character will do
as long as they're around like two
meters tall second I'll sketch in the
lighting using the ultra Dynamic Sky
plug-in now you can use unreal's default
lighting setup but UDS is just too good
I'll add some clouds and crank the fog
slider for now and we'll dial these
settings in later but the last thing we
need to do is bust out a camera so I'll
grab a cine camera actor from the place
actors window and pick a focal length
that we like knowing our camera angle
early on is crucial for focusing our
creativity on what the camera sees cause
you guys know it's a waste of time to
work on the stuff the camera is not
gonna see and now that our scene scales
determined are lighting sketched in and
we got a nice camera angle it's time for
the fun stuff let's build out this
environment so there is this amazing
free asset Library built into Unreal
Engine called quicksole bridge and I'll
browse their selection of snowy 3D
assets download the nanite meshes and
add them to my scene and I'll just drop
the assets in and try and build out the
environment in my reference image now
you'd be surprised at how much you can
get away with just rotating and scaling
the same asset it really does feel like
playing with Legos because all this
stuff is done in real time too now I got
these trees from cgtrader.com and they
didn't really import correctly they're
broken up into multiple parts and the
pivot Points all jacked up small stuff
like this can really get in the way of
our creativity so let me show you how
I'm solving these issues in unreal to
combine the two parts of this tree into
one mesh I'll grab both of the tree
objects in the world outliner and go to
actor convert actors static mesh which
gives us a single mesh to play with this
not only speeds up our workflow but also
helps with performance too in the center
of this ridiculous pivot point you can
right click where you want to set the
new pivot point and go to Pivot set
pivot offset here but you have to right
click again and click set as pivot
offset to lock it in which is super
annoying so I made a custom shortcut for
both of these actions definitely set
custom shortcuts for your most used
actions it helps your workflow it speeds
everything up and it makes creating so
much less of a drag and with these trees
looking good we have everything we need
to start setting up our Loop and the
first thing we gotta do to get a loop
going is set up a timeline or a sequence
as it's called an Unreal Engine by
right-clicking in the content browser
going to cinematics and selecting a
level sequence once inside I like to set
my frame rate to 24 for that cinematic
feel and let's give ourselves some
Runway by adding like a thousand frames
or so now we only need to add the
objects we want to animate to this
sequence so I'll just drag in my camera
and the character and I'm gonna set up a
basic tracking shot that follows our
character as they walk forward into the
fog on frame one just keyframe the
position of your camera scrub forward in
time and Dolly forward till our
environment is barely out of view and
you'll see a second keyframe was
automatically created and since these
keyframes ease in and out of the camera
move which we don't want it messes up
our Loop I'll right click and set both
of them to linear so the camera move
just goes straight through now hit play
and see if you like the speed stretch
the second keyframe out if you want to
slow it down or pull it back to make it
faster and once you're happy with the
speed this one's important alright guys
are you with me once you're happy with
the speed take a look at the numerical
difference between your start position
and your end position all right this is
a very important number it's our Loop
number it's how many units we need to
duplicate everything to make our scene
Loop so I suggest you round this number
up or even change it to an easy whole
number that you can remember because
we'll be be typing it in a lot for me
that number was 1700 so if the camera is
moving 1700 units forward that means
your character needs to move 1700 units
forward to match our starting position
and if we group all of our environment
objects together duplicate that group
and move it 1700 units forward it also
matches our first frame the number one
thing to remember with looping renders
is your first frame must perfectly match
your last frame it's kind of as easy as
that if if your first frame matches your
last frame you're set so let's duplicate
our environment forward a few more times
until we lose it in the fog and now our
first frame perfectly matches up with
our last frame and the cut point is
completely hidden look but is there a
way for our changes and updates to the
original environment be reflected onto
these duplicate environments because
otherwise we're just gonna have to
duplicate every single change a bunch of
times and I'm not doing that so check
this out let's grab all our environment
meshes and click convert selection to
blueprint class this will essentially
make a pre-comp like an After Effects
that'll update across all your
duplicates no matter how many times you
duplicate it and it's super helpful for
our workflow because now we can clean up
our seam and make any last minute tweaks
to our environment all in real time one
very important tip though these objects
inside the blueprint must be set to
static you'll get weird render glitches
otherwise so don't forget it and I gotta
give a shout out to Peter for getting me
on this blueprint tip you say me so much
freaking time thank you dude but this
render ain't done because we got to add
a sweet photo scan character we gotta
simulate a windy Poncho and we gotta add
some snow to our scene but first I gotta
shout out Asus for sponsoring this video
they hooked me up with their new Pro
Arts Studio Book Pro 16 OLED laptop and
I've really enjoyed everything it brings
to the table while I'm working on the go
and it's packed with Hardware to make
creating scenes like this possible from
anywhere in the world first off it's
equipped with a gorgeous color accurate
16 inch 4K OLED display which gives you
those true black values and the perfect
color accuracy you're going for when
dialing in your look comes loaded with
an Intel I9 processor and Nvidia RTX
A3000 with 12 gigabytes of vram a
flexible memory configuration with up to
64 gigs of physical RAM and a four
terabyte SSD drive for quick file
transfer and boot times for all your
applications I've definitely gotten
hooked on this Asus dial 2 which lets
you control things brightness and volume
on the fly but also allows for mapping
of custom inputs like brush size
saturation or layer opacity it's
actually pretty sweet and the pro art
Creator Hub lets you customize the dial
settings as well as performance color
and screen calibration now I've really
enjoyed this laptop it actually has
become a permanent addition to my 3D
workflow for on-the-go creativity it's
just an all-around solid Pro grade
laptop now if you're considering a
portable workstation for yourself or
maybe a really nice gift for someone
during the holidays check out the Asus
Pro R Studio Book Pro 16 OLED laptop I
got a link down in the description for
you guys clicking that link it
definitely helps me out and supports
more videos like this on the channel but
thank you for your time guys let's get
back to the art let's add some snow
using Ultra Dynamic Sky it's actually as
easy as dragging out the UDS weather
blueprint typing snow and enabling it
you can adjust the weather speed the
wind direction the snow amount the wind
fog and a whole bunch of other stuff
it's crazy how powerful this plugin is
let's go back into our UDS lighting
actor and tweak this fog because I want
to see a mountain peering out from above
it all if we type fog into the details
panel we can turn on volumetric fog
which always makes things look a bit
more realistic let's also tweak the base
fog density and foggy density
contribution to get thicker looking fog
and here's the secret sauce if we adjust
the foggy height fog falloff slider it
will effectively lower the fog and
reveal this sweet looking mountain I
snuck into the background it's just a
scaled up Mega scans asset but it
totally works alright so the environment
looks sweet but let's create a custom
photo scanned motion captured character
complete with a simulated Poncho now at
first I was like where am I gonna get a
quick and cheap hiker looking character
that doesn't look like trash well I
remembered my photo scan from alternate
realities it's got the right clothes
it's got the right backpack it's perfect
so for any good photo scan you need a
bunch of TAC sharp high quality photos
and I made a couple videos I'll link
here if you guys want to get into some
photo scanning over the break it's
actually super fun but a friend of mine
shot these images while I tried to stand
as still as possible I dropped the image
set into reality capture my go-to
photogrammetry software I align the
images I meshed it I cleaned things up
textured it and got something that looks
totally awesome in order to animate this
guy we need to ring him up and I'm gonna
do that the fast way with miximo adobe's
free motion capture Library I'll drop my
model in tell it where all my weak
points are and hit go and it'll bounce
back in auto rigged model it's pretty
sweet I'll just export it in a t-posed
state so that it's ready to be attached
to custom motion capture data which
means I'm busting out the Rococo
smartsuit Pro 2 and pretending to hike
to the top of a mountain but we want our
data to Loop right so check this out in
Rococo studio if you hold shift and
click click drag in the timeline it'll
actually Loop that selection you can
even control the transition time align
the data along a certain axis and even
lock the loop in place and after a quick
export it's time to connect my rigged
character to the mocap data we just shot
now you can totally use blender for this
or whatever program but I'm just going
to use c4d because it's my personal
program of choice I'll add a character
definition tag to each joint tree and
for each tag I'll open the manager
extract the skeleton and set the
reference pose this basically scans The
Joint trees and preps them to merge with
one another now on our custom character
I'll create a solver and drag our mocap
character's definition tag and into the
source character slot I've got a whole
tutorial on literally this whole step
because it can be a little tricky but
look at this our custom character is
successfully paired to the custom mocap
data so now we can model some hiking
poles drop them onto the hand joints and
laugh at how bad this looks but the fix
is super easy we just gotta select the
hiking pole in its hand joint parent go
to character and create an ik chain it
locks the bottom of the hiking pole in
place without having to hand animate
things now all we have to do is animate
the goals to move appropriately with the
feet and just remember we're going for a
looping animation so make sure the first
frame is exactly the same as the last
frame and we're all set next I want to
bring this animation to life with a
simulated Poncho because one of the most
memorable moments of that hike for me
was how the wind completely tore our
ponchos to shreds by the time we made it
to the top so let's model the world's
crappiest looking Minecraft Poncho we'll
subdivide it we'll throw a cloth tag on
it and hit play Sweet all right it's
working but we can do better so in the
cloth tag I'll up its mass just a little
bit I'll lower the stretchiness and in
our project settings under simulation
I'll add like 60 sub steps for a more
accurate simulation let's get some
turbulent wind going though and to have
it randomly rotate I'm using a signal
tag from grayscale gorilla which lets me
add random loopable noise to any key
frameable parameter in this case our
y-axis rotation on the Wind object since
our first and last frame are exactly the
same I'm going to trim one frame off the
end only on export so we don't see a
duplicate frame on our final Loop now
let's bake all this as an Olympic export
as an Olympic import it into unreal as a
geometry cache drop it into the
sequencer select the Geocache we just
imported animate the character 1700
units forward again your number will
probably be different than that but yeah
this is looking pretty good here I used
all the same cloth Sim techniques to add
this torn flag to our scene as well for
a nice little touch now before we render
this out for post processing which we're
going to get to in a second let's do a
couple things to ensure it Loops nicely
now if I were to export my Loop now and
play it back with itself you'd see the
snow pop in like this because
technically it needs a handful of frames
to start up so to fix this I'll extend
my timeline by three times for a total
of three loops and set my in and out
points to that middle Loop then I can
add 30 frame handles to the start and
ending points to give me a bit more
Runway so that I can cross the solve
this render into itself when we get into
the post-processing stage in just a
second next let's get nerdy and talk
about some render settings I'm using the
movie render queue it's found here it's
in your sequencer window and if you
don't see it you just need to enable the
plugin I got a pretty basic setup we're
working with an exr sequence set to dwaa
compression to give us the most bang for
our buck when it comes to color
correcting and controlling our image
later I got some anti-aliasing going as
well to smooth out any rough edges and
clean up our motion blur now you'll want
to check this override anti-lezing box
right here and I'm using 16 samples this
time around because of the quick moving
snow particles and simulated Poncho in
general though try to keep this number
as low as possible because it's just
going to renders 16 times per frame now
for every single frame next I'm using a
couple console commands mainly r dot
screen percentage set to 150 which will
essentially render your sequence at 1.5
times larger than your output resolution
then scale that larger render down to
fit inside that same output resolution
it's just a way to make your renders
look cleaner and finally an r dot motion
blur quality variable set to 4. again
because of the snow particles and the
Poncho and that's it I like rendering at
4K because I can especially in Unreal
Engine and just point your exr sequence
to a folder of your choosing and hit
render because now we're going to hop
into DaVinci Resolve and really bring
the most out of this animation so I'm in
the edit Tab and I'll just drag all my
images into the timeline so it can Auto
detect this image sequence now let's
color the images first then smooth out
the loop after so I'll hop into the
color tab where I'll make a new node
with alt s and I'll tweak The Shadow
Shadows the mid-tones and highlights
until I'm happy with my look and maybe
add another node for a subtle vignette
or something but nothing too crazy let's
hop back into the edit tab where I'll
add some lens blur to remove that 3D
Pixel Perfect Look and I'll add a touch
of camera Shake as well finally just a
bit of film grain from gorilla grain.com
adding film grain is like the most
important part to making your 3D
renderer not look 3D which is exactly
what we're going for and to finalize the
loop I'll just duplicate and stack these
renders drop the opacity on the top
layer and walk it back to the frames
match trim the clips cross dissolve the
cut say your in and out points and we
are wrapped
[Music]
if you all enjoyed hanging out and
learning something new with me in this
video definitely subscribe if you're not
subscribed already leave a comment down
below what are you trying to do in 2023
what are you trying to learn it's been
an incredible Year guys thank you so
much for hanging out with me on the
channel uh for watching these videos for
learning with me we got through two
incredible Community render challenges
we made some awesome videos we learned a
lot this year and I'm excited to take a
break I'm excited to reflect on the year
and make some cool new goals for 2023
because I want to get into some new
stuff you know we can't do the same
thing all the time you gotta mix it up
thank you guys so so much have a great
holiday break I'll see you guys in 2023
peace out later
[Music]